are you playing around with a powerful
complex image classification model
and training it in collab or kaggle
notebooks
but it takes too long to train with the
free gpus
stay tuned to learn how you can
instantly scale to train
with more data more gpus and on larger
scale
welcome to ai adventures where we
explore the arts
science and tools of machine learning i
am priyanka vergaria and today we're
talking about
scaling machine learning training
resources right from within collab and
kaggle notebooks
using tensorflow cloud let's say you're
playing around with a powerful complex
image classification model such as nas
net
and training it in cola it takes a
couple of hours to train with a free gpu
that collab gives you
also it may not even be feasible to
train on large data sets because the
training could go over the free 12 hours
window
wouldn't it be nice if i could instantly
scale
to training on more data and with more
gpus
and once you have the model trained you
often need to run multiple experiments
to fine-tune and optimize the hyper
parameters
to continue to improve your model
hundreds of runs are needed sometimes
to find the setting that results in the
best accuracy
if you participate in a competition on
kaggle you know that often
very small accuracy differences separate
winners in the leaderboard
this kind of experimentation takes a
very long time
and a lot of resources wouldn't it be
nice if you could run
all these experiments concurrently using
more resources
well that's where tensorflow cloud comes
in
it's a client-side library for training
your tensorflow model on vertex ai
it provides apis for a seamless
transition from local debugging
to distributed training and hyper
parameter tuning within google cloud
you can directly use it from a collab
notebook or
a kaggle kernel it handles cloud
specific tasks such as creating virtual
machine instances
and distribution strategies for your
model automatically
for distributed tuning jobs tensorflow
cloud sets up
model callbacks to capture model
checkpoints and
tensorboard logs automatically now
i'm sure you're excited to see how it
works so let's take a peek into it
first we will run the initial one-time
setup to
make sure the google cloud assets are
all configured
link to this collab is included in the
description below
for that we set up the project in the
google cloud console at cloud.google.com
and grab the project name and the
project number
in the colab or kaggle notebook you're
using plug those in
link to this notebook is included in the
description below
then make a choice depending on where
you're running the notebook
i'm using collab here so i will set up
odd for collab notebook here
but if you're using kaggle then do the
same for kaggle
you need a billing account attached to
your google cloud project so the next
step
is to link your billing account when you
entered your credit card information
during google cloud
sign up it created a default billing
account for you
that's the one we are going to use here
next
enable the required cloud apis including
the vertex ai apis which will allow us
to kick off the training jobs within
google cloud
and the cloud build api to build our
docker images
we create a storage bucket in this step
to store
our temporary assets and to save the
model checkpoints
now if you're going to also perform
hyperparameter tuning
then we need a service account which is
a special kind of account
used by the tensorflow cloud tuner to
create the hyper parameter tuning jobs
in vertex ai
in this step we are creating that
service account and providing it the
right
access to create the job at this point
we have our setup complete
with a project in google cloud a service
account that will create
jobs in vertex ai and the cloud storage
bucket that will store our model assets
we can reuse this setup with various
notebooks in each notebook you will need
to repeat the step two
to add the google cloud auth credentials
to your notebook
this will allow your notebook to connect
to the project now that the setup is out
of the way
let's run some distributed training and
see how tensorflow cloud helps scale the
distributed training resources in google
cloud
this example is based on the image
classification we are fine tuning
with efficient net to train a nas net
mobile model
first step import all the requirements
then
set the project parameters that we got
from our setup notebook
and authenticate the notebook to our
google cloud project
then we load and prepare the data split
it into training and test data sets
add a pre-processing less api for image
augmentation
image resizing rotation flip and
contrast
next we load the model and prepare for
training
here we load a nas net mobile
pre-trained model with weights
and unfreeze a few layers for
fine-tuning the model
to better match the data set then train
the model
using model.fit but notice the remote
function it determines whether your code
is being executed locally
or in the cloud and allows for the
separate destination
of fit parameters for local and remote
execution
now we're ready to train the model
remotely on google cloud platform
we submit a training job using this step
where we
define the parameters within the run
function our distribution strategy
requirements for any custom models
docker configuration
and master and worker machine
configurations
once done we can monitor our job
intensive board
this may take a few minutes as the logs
start to populate once the training
begins
now that we know how to kick off a
training job using tensorflow cloud
execute a distributed hyper parameter
tuning job yourself
it's fairly similar you will be using
the cloud tuner function
which defines tuning parameters for your
hyperparameter tuning jobs
that are executed concurrently on google
cloud platform
you also get to define the distribution
strategy
the custom modules in requirements.txt
the docker image
and the number of concurrent tuning jobs
that you want to run
if you run into any question watch my
walkthrough in the video linked below
all right in this episode we talked
about scaling machine learning training
resources
using tensorflow cloud give it a try
yourself
using the links below and let me know
how it goes in the comments
if you like this video give us a like
and subscribe if you have any questions
reach me on twitter at pivoguardia
you